je dis voilà alors si on va la faire ce
soir on va faire une dernière et après
bien sûr la semaine prochaine on va se
retrouver dans un nouveau plateau vous
allez voir pour une nouvelle émission
qui s'appellera c'est que du kif
on va parler d'art cas médias olympiades
je pense que ça va vous plaire on veut
vous détendre la voilà je vous le dis
jusqu'à la fin juin jusqu'au 18 juin 28
juin je sais pas jusqu'à quand on va les
2 juillet en tout cas on va être dans la
détente puisque après le 18 mai il ya à
prendre ou à laisser qui arrive donc les
boîtes et bien sûr c'est que du kif à
19h à prendre à l'essai à 20 heures et
je vous dis pour la rentrée je vous
prépare un retour de tp exceptionnel je
vous jure que c'est vrai ça y est j'ai
dit on à déjà préparer notre conducteur
et je vous dis on va revenir un
conducteur comme un peu dans les années
2000 2015-2016 voilà avec deux
chroniques par jour
je vous le dis sur des images on va
revenir sur le hier à la télé vous
retrouverez votre élire à la télé vos
coups de gueule vos coups de coeur coups
de griffes chose à brumath
voilà on est en train de faire le
conducteur ce qu'il fallait pas louper
bien entendu voilà tout ça vous
retrouverez tous vos rendez vous il y
aura un énorme rendez vous je vous dis
ce soir je peux pas vous en dire plus
même les chroniqueurs ne le savent pas
non je vous le dévoile rien au très
prochainement les cherry et bien sûr il
y aura nos chroniqueurs historique et
puis y aura des nouveautés vous verrez
et qui vont arriver petit à petit mais
sachez le sai et l'équipe est faite
l'équipe est complète pour l'année
prochaine pour tpm pays ça y est c'est
par voie la une où une place près voilà
c'est bon voilà ça y est on a on a on a
on a notre équipe